michael fassbender what's it in Jane  Eyre you had a horse oh yeah you had a  very bad behavior on Jane Eyre yeah  Prince and was divorce yeah so what  would happen well he used to get quite  aroused when whenever I got in his back  yeah yeah Dan the horse handler had to  get on it and sort of you know contra  more give him a little trot so it's sort  of slap off his is he attracted back in  and then it was good to go until you got  on again and then I got a hand and  caught yeah you caught it about in your  lovely Jane Eyre  ended up under the table with a very  famous action I can't remember who it  was we were putting lightly actors can  we were putting the whole world to write  well was it still in your tongue can you  see yeah it's great for oral sex